Well Bank was created in 1944 before the
world war two Sargo was over.
It was created together with the
Monetary Fund,
International Monetary Fund and what it
was going to be late to the WTO,
the World Trade Organization in the case
of the bank.
Uh,
its main purpose was to borrow money on
the markets in those days,
Europe more than the u s and to lend
this money for the reconstruction of
Europe,
of Japan and so forth.
So it was very bold design for the
times.
And it did that in the 50s.
Mostly it was in during construction
business.
It finance the reconstruction for
instance of Toyota in the in Japan or
the financing for the reconstruction of
the French railway system came from
there.
Then in the 60s that preconstruction job
was over.
It went into developing country
business,
uh,
lending for hospitals,
for highways or ports for agriculture in
the developing world,
starting mostly in Latin America and
then going worldwide.
And it really became the World Bank that
is known today under Mcnamara.
And Mcnamara came from the u s
government to become a very famous
president of the World Bank in the 70s.
He made it grow to a much bigger place
than it was originally.
Originally.
Ted Let less than a thousand people in
Washington and today it has 12,000
people roughly.
And he got the World Bank into social
areas,
into education,
into hell's,
into nutrition,
into what was called basic needs,
integrated rural development and so
forth.
And so it became the largest and most,
uh,
sort of broadest development institution
in the world.
And that it is still today,
even though it's a very much change.
Well,
there's still a lot of that work to be
done.
It still operates by borrowing money in
the markets by issuing bonds,
using the money for very long term
loans,
which all have to do with some
development purpose.
And then when the loans get three
reimbursed by the clients,
uh,
we repaid to bondholders.
That's the,
the way the World Bank works for the
very poor countries.
It has a special Katie,
which is not based on borrowing money.
It's based on donated money.
It's called the International
Development Association window or Idi
Window.
And that leads to very long term loans
without an interest rate,
uh,
or on grand terms for very poor
countries under roughly a thousand
dollars per person.
So it's an institution that's a sort of
bank in a way.
There is a sort of financial function,
financing function,
but it's also full of people who have a
lot of knowledge of what works and
doesn't work in education and road
surfacing and building latrines in a
textbook,
publications for schools,
uh,
and cataract operations,
you name it.
So it's not just a money bank,
it's a knowledge bank at the same time.
And lately it has become very active
also in a big global issues like global
warming,
uh,
the ozone depletion,
the pollution of the seas and so forth.
So it is still mainly in the poverty
reduction business and the development
business,
but it's beginning to become a presence
in the global issues business as well.